why don't you stop - max Pemberton and  in the latest issue of spectator health  we take a look at ISA Guerette and  vaping now some doctors have been quite  critical of this phenomena was actually  in fact if you look at the evidence  you'll find that tobacco kills both  nicotine doesn't I get a nicotine  possible and I know that why do you see  another vapor and you say oh well what  brand are you using you know how long  have you not been smoking for and then  you know it can't be an icebreaker  you can I mean people might think you're  just chewing the end of a pen I tend to  go for those that are least like the  flavors that you can get a ever  increasing in some people will have a  cappuccino flavor late in the morning  followed by a fruit salad at brunch time  and then maybe it's an atomic flavoured  one amazing